[Música]
jubilee reunimos a siete fans de cani
soy fan de cani soy fan de cani soy fan
de calle soy fan de cráneo y fan de
kenia soy fan de kanye soy fan de cani
al 100% uno no es un fan si el grupo
descubre quién es el impostor se
repartirán un premio en efectivo
y si el impostor sobrevive ganará todo
el premio quien es el impostor
deberíamos presentarnos es decir nuestra
canción favorita soy su sin mi canción
favorita es lost in the world mi nombre
es bruce mi canción favorita es viver
sweet ports y
mi nombre es alex me canse en esa
meissen me llamo chase y mi canción
favorita es bound to me llamo care y mi
canción favorita es never let me down me
llamo todo en mi canción favorita
esperemos me llamo jack y mi canción
favorita es sin pablo pero cuál es su
álbum favorito de todos lo llevo en el
pecho mismo lo tengo aquí
para mí sí estoy de acuerdo si life of
pablo si cuando thay dijo su canción
favorita jack dijo que era la misma y yo
pensé eso es un poco raro has ido a
verlo en concierto triste veces lo
hizo
jaycee
hermano
hermano estábamos cantando y mi padre
trabajaba en la seguridad en ese momento
y por eso me dejaba pasar por debajo del
escenario
pero buen lugar lo vi en medo news ix
festival donde se fue por kim kardashian
siendo hoy una emergencia familiar tengo
que parar el show
salió me río del escenario 40 minutos
maravillosos y luego fue como mi dinero
se fue porque porque me robaste más de
lo que ya me había formado la
experiencia todos los temas solo dieron
el tiempo y fue parte de un episodio fue
genial
el voto de los seguidores quién es el
topo
vote por alix solo porque ella estaba un
poco más en el lado tranquilo la primera
ronda y no se involucró pero supongo que
yo tampoco así que no puedo decir mucho
ella fue demasiado entusiasta para mí
por lo que sospeche que tal vez tendría
algo que ocultar
se destacó porque no sobresalió
lo siento
[Aplausos]
buena suerte solo pude decir como cuatro
palabras en cámara y creo que solo dije
sin pablo y mi nombre y luego fue
eliminado del mundo tras años de ser fan
de caña como como lo defiendo en aragón
que creo que todos sabemos qué quiere
decir cuando habla pero yo lo que creo
es que le cuesta mucho expresarse no
habría trabajo scott no habría ninguna
de estas de acuerdo zonas influyentes y
sin él es difícil alejarse de él incluso
cuando hace cosas problema voy a dejar
que haga lo que hace y ocuparme de mis
propios asuntos
yo lo separó como un diseñador músico y
paul y él tiene un viaje realmente
humano a través de todo especialmente
desde que está siendo tan abierto sobre
lo que vive al ser bipolar no creo que
eso sea fácil lo admiro por tratar de
hablar y por la forma en que lo hace no
como la sociedad dice así es como se
supone que debes comportarte cuál fue el
momento en el que todos supieron que era
un fan de kanye west crecí escuchando
kanye west mi madre lo ponía cuando
limpiaba pasado me ponía ella como
colesterol muy bueno ustedes saben si
viví una experiencia similar mi madre lo
ponía en la mi familia odia a este
hombre
y vamos un fin de semana sí y otro no y
escogí a leigh
era una niña mamá lo puso y yo allí supe
sus respuestas parecen enmarcarse en
torno a solo el viejo carné no tanto el
nuevo carné el momento que se me quedó
grabado fue cuando veía los vídeos
musicales por en ti vivía este artista
en lo suyo como han dicho crecimos
juntos porque cada vez que saca algo es
como si estuviéramos allí con él durante
todo el viaje no es por ser malo pero
parecía muy simple muy fan de paxson y
realmente no me importaba la música en
general hasta como el último año de la
secundaria sólo recuerdo que el aifos
pablo estaba a punto de salir y tenía
mucha curiosidad porque estaba leyendo
la página de wikipedia acerca de cómo
eran tres pablos 1r sobarzo siguen el
caso no sé es un entorno tan diferente
dijo los tres pablos y luego no sabía el
tercer pablo yo estaba como eso es
sospechoso mi primo me puso a kanye
cuando era más joven y entonces fue
cuando empecé a desarrollar realmente mi
amor por él
digo que sea un stand no sé hombre
tienes un tatuaje de él
para este vídeo lo tengo no tengo los
ángeles tan podemos ver los ángeles
miren eso esa no esté que es fuerte
ella fue la menos involucrada en mi
opinión personal
kerry no me dio la seguridad de que
fuera una verdadera fan de cani
[Música]
quería estuvo bien ella estaba jugando
una táctica de hacer preguntas pero
seguir observando
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no estaba muy animada creo que en
realidad solo estaba escuchando y
observando y tal vez lo tomaron como una
señal de algún tipo de disimulo si se
sienten seguros de que ya atraparon al
topo pueden terminar el juego pero si la
mayoría tiene dudas el juego continuará
por favor levanten la mano si quieren
seguir jugando
eso es la mayoría a partir de ahora cada
vez que eliminen a alguien que no sea el
topo se va a reducir el total del premio
en esta ronda van a elegir una canción
de caña y van a completar la letra del
otro 1 por 1 podemos decir las groserías
porque vas a pasar de todo
esta es una canción bastante notable en
el álbum muy bien vamos a ir en fila es
malo es sister como la mujer misma
chinches de cama
[Risas]
eso
es
lo que sinceramente me puse muy nervioso
y luego olvidé completamente todo siento
que todos somos y tenemos favoritos
diferentes es la canción más miscelánea
de ese álbum no recuerdo muy bien en
este momento
round este hombre de aquí no sé a dónde
vamos a partir de ahí
podemos cantar power alix eligió power
para que pudiéramos ir de un lado a otro
ya que es una canción muy popular esta
es una canción que todos se saben o son
todos y todos cantamos el adiós bien
intentémoslo sí
jay bruce como que estaba en un bucle
porque no podía realmente salir de ahí
tal vez dejó de ser su fan después de la
época en que se tatuó
ahora
descansados
creo que no nos acercamos a adivinar a
nadie parecía un desvío en la
investigación fue como si escupido
tuviera un episodio musical
[Música]
tenemos un empate es un empate de 5
en un minuto para averiguar quién es el
topo todos lo queremos pero seamos un
poco críticos lo peor que ha dicho fue
esclavitud fue una elección y 100% otra
cosa que dijo fue que salió al aire para
lo de la cruz roja por el huracán
katrina dijo que esa fue una de las
malas en el concierto y el tipo estaba
en la silla de ruedas no puedo decir la
palabra ya lo dijimos a
la presidencia bajo la bandera
republicana realmente hacer lo que
siempre
creo que lo del chico de la casa no sé
es decir tuvo esa entrevista en la que
se hizo hazlo tú mismo
pero no se me ocurra puedes no de verdad
estoy como de acuerdo hombre no no puedo
seguir defendiendo te en estas calles
me pareció muy carismático y luego muy
emocionado al que llevaba unas
zapatillas nike así que pensé que eso
era bastante sospechoso
los quiero chicos
para ser honesto no sean realmente
porque me eliminaron por favor levanten
la mano si quieren seguir jugando
de acuerdo el juego terminará ahora si
las luces son verdes significa que
eliminaron al impostor y ganaron si las
luces son rojas significa que el topo
sigue aquí y perdieron
[Música]
así que son tatuajes reales estoy
sorprendida pensé que haremos a cada
alto podría el falso fan de kanye dar un
paso adelante y revelarse en 3 2 1
[Música]
en cada uno
ya no soy su fan pero creo que cuando
tienes una plataforma exitosa e
influencia es tu responsabilidad ser
consciente de tus acciones y de lo que
dices no pude seguir siendo su fan por
eso si
y dije qué